axel plunica joins us now from the
cologne institute for economic research
what's the future look like for europe's
economic engine
that's quite difficult for germany
because of demographic change
germany
will lose 10 million inhabitants in the
next
decades
and so there will be a lack of nearly 1
million people in the technical fields
that's quite important for germans
innovation
and economic growth so is germany
in danger of losing its status as
europe's economic engine yes it
might be
but there are still some
chances for germany
if we get or if we attract more
immigrants from other country
or if we
are able that people work longer that we
have a better full day schools that
mothers can work so we can
we can try to get more high skilled
workers in germany but it's quite
difficult
taking us a step back the birth rate
here at the moment is extremely low
how do you encourage people to have kids
it's quite difficult the
ministry for family
they have a lot of money but
they didn't change
the birth rate in the last three decades
throwing money at people to have more
kids basically doesn't work yes
perhaps we need a better
better
chance for for families to work and
that's quite
difficult in germany
to work so a stronger education system
yes we need a full school days we need
early childhood education and that could
improve the situation that families
both mother and father can work full day
let's have a look at the figures that
show us just how old germany is getting
in europe the average age in germany at
the moment is over 45. if we compare
that into nationally europe levels out
to about 40 asia just under 29 latin
america 27 and north africa just 24
years of age i mean that's a big
difference
and this is something that germany's
known about for a long time um how come
germany can't tackle this problem yes
was not able germany was not able to
change the birth rate and the birth rate
is
just
1.31.4
and other
other
countries in the world like india have
much higher rates so the population
growth is
too low in germany so
the economic growth
will decrease in germany and that's a
big problem and
we have to attract our country we have
to attract more immigrants from other
countries how exactly how exactly uh yes
we have improved our rules
if you think on the
blue card or
other rules especially for people with a
vocational training and what does the
blue card do for people the blue card if
you come from
countries outside the european union
then it's much easier to get a job in
germany you need a
wage as an engineer from 33 000 euros
that's
no no
problem for the labor market to get such
a job
and so it's easier especially if you
studied in germany then it's quite easy
to stay here and to work and also
attracting those sorts of people would
solve the skills shortage which germany
is also tackling at the moment a whole
lot of problems all at once yes because
the immigrants
who studied in germany they studied
engineer perhaps engineering medicine
medicine and that's
the jobs where we have a lack in germany
polinika thank you very much for your
time